- [Narrator] This is wicket, a red panda.
At 10 years old, Wicket
is a fully grown male
with a height of just over two feet
or slightly larger than
your average house cat.
As cute as he is, his population
has decreased dramatically,
with less than 10,000 left in the wild.
(upbeat music)
Red panda in name, it
is not closely related
to the giant panda, but actually closer
to the raccoon family.
He loves to eat bamboo,
but won't turn down the occasional bird,
insect or mammal for a snack.
Native to the eastern Himalayas
and southwestern China,
red pandas live in trees and
are nimble, agile climbers.
Their reddish brown fur and
bushy tails camouflage them
in their habitat from
predators, like snow leopards.
Besides other animals,
humans pose a major threat,
poaching and hunting them for their fur.
The forests that they live
in are shrinking fast,
and estimates say that their
population has been cut in half
in the last 20 years.
This is the red panda.